KA YREALATIT, ED.
>>> SO MIKE PENCE ISINR THAT HED
SUPPORT FOR DONALD TRUMP.
FENU VOTER HIM? WELL, THEBODY
G TURE.
OURSOU
G THAT PENCE
OFFICEE K A FUTURE RUN.ME NOWEL.
E.SWER ANDHAAT PHE REPUBLICA
PRIMARL,HE FS TO RUN FOR
BUT A GOOD FHT HAVE
N
NOW AT OF LANE FOR FORMEDEYES,
AGGRESSIVELYN  C
OMRCLES.
JUN,T D NCE D SUDDLYLE
POTEL 20E RO
SANII IS
SO I THINK HE'IX IO IMAGINE HI
FIG  LANE.BUO NOT  I
E RIGHT
PUTTING TOGETHER A TEAM, I'M
WE'LL SEE HOAD
TS OF MOVE TALK ABOUT PRESID
HE'S DOIG POLITICAL LLFOR JOHN .
WHICH IS SHIA BREAK
FROMRA O
PAST PRESIDENTS.
TRUMP LOVED RALLIES.
A CROWD WHENHINK THEY'REDING?
IS IT MORE ABO OR JUST
E VINM
OT
TTH OF
THOSE IS Y
JOE BIDEN IS NOT RALLYING
KINDF
HE WAS NAS RUNNING R PRESIDENT.B
E FIRST PARTE DEMOCR
PRIMARY, HVE AALLEST OF ANY  HI
AND HE WON THCYOUT MANYLI AL.
HET NOT E RALLNG
SO
THEY ACKNOWLGEE HIM.NG
HIERE ARTHAT WS WITHO WANT TO
SPEAKT HITS
BUT THERIS A DEMOCRAWHO WILL BE
TH IMA.
HIS AGE. NEXT WEEK IN GEOIAONS
HE  BEING I
AL DID, ITRKR HIM.BUT RALLIES A
NOT SURE HH ITEDAL FOR JOE
SO THE SENATE RACE EETE, WES Y.
W N
INTERESTG O A REALLY
ACE.ATOU
T DE HE'S  TALKINDG OR TAKF.IS A
MOMENTUM IS?
BER FORCE ON BASE ANDREWS AN
JOET WL
PITTURA
THISNING WHERE HE
THE COUNTR VER FUNDRAISEWIBUT, S
UNIQUE DYNAMICS.
A STROKE EAR ANDANJOHN F
HE'SOTCA
BE.RLYS
S GNS THEY RELEASED A AY
FR DOCTOR SAYINGFIT ERA SE BUT
SE OCESSI'T HEAIL R
AND ATOZGNED OT,OF COURSE HAEMEF
T CAMPAIGNING IN
HEAT PENNSYLVAA
VOTO WHO
S OFTRYING TO GO BACK  AS R.E HI
WHY THE SYLVANIASO
SEAT. S, I HA T  REPUBLICANSAT
IN.O TO THE WHITE
O IA.O REPORTERS.
LET'S LISTEN TO THAT.
ORU.AND THE BRITISH ARE GOING
SOLVE THEIR PROBLEMS
>> D>> CAN YOU RERNED ABVER EFFA
CO
>> JOHN FETTERWI
YOU TODAY YLVANIA.
VEN'T BEEN THAMA
CAATNG WH YOU.
THERE HAS BEEN 15.
COUNT.
>> THERE ARE GOING TO BEN
MORE. >> YEAH.
RESTRICTIONS ON ABORTION
RE.ET ALL RIG.WADE.
IDINSO QUESTIONSS  MARINE ONE.
THSTILL
T LO THINGS.
FIRST FOREMOST HIS FIRST OIORESU
BO,
CAMPAIGNINESIDEN
HOW MANY CTE TO CAEM.
>>UT THE ITISH PRE S ER BRIEF
DIDN'T MENTION
T A BRIER
STATEMENT.
E US
T TIME AT  BRIEF.
STRDS WHICH WA
INR BACK TO IF HE'S IN DEMON THE
.TI
TORY A COUPLE OFABOUT E CE ONE I
BATTLE, , THECSE
WA WITH JOIS
UEHIS PARTS
S SYLVANIA IS A PLACE HE
ES.REG N
A PIGH -RSANT VOTERS TO FO